es posible que usted o uno de sus seres
queridos haya sido diagnosticado
recientemente con cáncer de vejiga este
vídeo le ayudará a comprender algunas de
las opciones de tratamiento disponibles
el tipo más frecuente de cáncer de
vejiga llamado carcinoma urotelial o
carcinoma de células transicionales es
una enfermedad en la que se forman
células cancerosas en el tejido que
recubre el interior de la vejiga
los tratamientos para el cáncer de
vejiga pueden incluir uno o más de los
siguientes cirugía radioterapia
quimioterapia e inmunoterapia
hay dos tipos principales de cirugía
para el cáncer de vejiga
el primer tipo se llama resección
transuretral de tumor de vejiga o rtvv
configuración para el cáncer en etapa
inicial durante este procedimiento se
inserta un tubo con iluminación llamado
cistoscopio en la vejiga
luego el tumor se extirpa con un asa de
alambre el tejido tumoral restante se
quema mediante un proceso llamado
fulguración
el segundo tipo de cirugía llamada
cistectomía es para el cáncer que se ha
propagado a la pared de la vejiga
durante unas stec tommy a parcial se
elimina la parte de la pared de la
vejiga que contiene un tumor pequeño
después de este tipo de cirugía es
posible que lo que resta de vejiga no
pueda contener mucha orina es posible
que necesite orinar con mayor frecuencia
en una cistectomía radical la vejiga
entera se extrae si el tumor es grande o
se encuentra en más de una parte de la
vejiga
también se eliminan los tejidos cercanos
como los ganglios linfáticos
en los hombres se extraerán la próstata
y las vesículas seminales
y en las mujeres con frecuencia se
extraerá en el útero los ovarios las
trompas de falopio y parte de la vagina
si le extirpa en la vejiga se puede usar
una parte de su intestino como un
conducto para que el cuerpo puede
eliminar la orina se drena a través de
una abertura en su abdomen y hacia una
bolsa pequeña o bien se puede formar una
pequeña bolsa con el intestino para
almacenar la orina antes de que pase a
través de la abertura en el abdomen en
este caso usted tiene que colocar un
pequeño tubo llamado catéter en la
abertura para vaciar la orina de la
bolsa
o bien si se preservó la uretra se puede
construir una vejiga nueva a partir de
un trozo del intestino para que la orina
pueda salir de su cuerpo de la manera
habitual
otra opción de tratamiento es la
radioterapia
utiliza radiación para matar las células
cancerosas o evitar que crezcan la
radioterapia de 'las externo utiliza una
máquina fuera del cuerpo que apunta la
radiación al cáncer
la radioterapia interna usa una fuente
radiactiva que emite radiación la fuente
radiactiva se coloca adentro del cuerpo
dentro o cerca del cáncer
la quimioterapia usa ciertos
medicamentos para destruir las células
cancerosas o detener su crecimiento
estos medicamentos se pueden administrar
por vía intravenosa para tratar las
células cancerosas en todo el cuerpo oa
través de un catéter para tratar las
células cancerosas dentro de la vejiga
la forma en que se administra la
quimioterapia depende de lo avanzado que
esté el cáncer de vejiga
la inmunoterapia ayuda a su sistema
inmunitario a combatir el cáncer el
cáncer a veces se puede esconder de las
células del sistema inmunitario que lo
atacan por ejemplo tanto el cáncer como
las células del sistema inmune pueden
tener proteínas llamadas proteínas de
punto de control si estas proteínas se
unen la célula del sistema inmunitario
no atacará la célula cancerosa algunos
medicamentos de inmunoterapia contra el
cáncer de vejiga evitan que las
proteínas de punto de control se unan
entre sí como resultado la célula del
sistema inmunitario puede atacar y
destruir la célula cancerosa otro
ejemplo de inmunoterapia se llama bs
consiste en un tipo de bacteria en una
solución
bcg se coloca dentro de la vejiga donde
desencadena una respuesta que mata a las
células cancerosas
si tiene alguna duda sobre el cáncer de
vejiga o cualquier medicamento que le
hayan recetado hable con su médico es
importante tomar sus medicamentos según
las indicaciones e informar de cualquier
efecto secundario que tenga